[Musica]
mollo tutto e apro un chiringuito tempo
fa avremmo detto così oggi si dice mollo
tutto e apro una startup basta capo
arrogante basta collega fancazzista
basta stage non remunerato o stipendio
striminzito apro una startup e divento
milionario case di lusso in Silicon
Valley jet privati feste milioni e
milioni di soldi arrivati da investitori
generosi Insomma una via una strada
dritta verso il successo e la felicità
e poi c'è la realtà che più una strada
tortuosa piena di buche in salita e
anche coi Burroni un viaggio dove la
distanza la durata e anche le risorse
necessarie per arrivare a destinazione
sono del tutto incerte Ecco perché alla
fine questi insieme di incertezze e
tutti i rischi che affronti farebbero
cadere i capelli anche chi non ce li ha
già
Ecco perché dico oggi in questo evento
del Ted X parlare di kimsuji E ho anche
ripetuto varie volte per dire kingsg
correttamente quindi ecco perché oggi
parlare di startup e raccontarvi la
storia della mia azienda e appropriato
perché voi forse non lo sapete ma solo
una startup su quattro ce la fa delle
altre non si raccolgono neanche i cocci
Cioè è proprio impossibile
riapriccicarli
e per tutte le startup c'è un primo stop
inevitabile la valle della morte che non
è una località del Grand Canyon ma è
piuttosto la Salerno Reggio Calabria
mentre cerchi un autogrill è il momento
in cui non sei né troppo grande come
azienda né troppo piccolo non sei né
carne né pesce stai soltanto cercando di
raccogliere più soldi possibili per
sopravvivere per arrivare al momento in
cui sarai autosufficiente Ecco questo
grafico difficilissimo in realtà vi fa
vedere che nel momento in cui sei nella
Valle della Morte hai già chiesto soldi
a nell'ordine i tuoi genitori il tuo
migliore amico i compagni delle
superiori poi sei passato allo zio
d'America infine continuato con gli
Angel hai fatto l'acceleratore l'equity
crowdfunding Insomma l'obiettivo
arrivare al tuo break even essere
autosufficienti Ecco Dalla Valle della
Morte ci siamo passati anche noi
e in realtà abbiamo iniziato nel 2011
quindi tanti anni fa con una startup che
comparava i prezzi dei supermercati
grande successo perché l'idea era nuova
abbiamo vinto premi negli Stati Uniti
abbiamo avuto tantissimi articoli sui
giornali amica Grazie a gente Come le
chiamo io se non so dei Coscialunga No
quelle cose un po' da donna e poi tanti
investitori interessati alla nostra
azienda abbiamo raccolto due milioni di
euro che erano lì sul nostro conto una
startup insuccesso No no perché in
realtà man mano che cerchi di capire
qual è il tuo business Model cioè come
fare soldi in realtà le tue casse si
svuotano quindi man mano vai drenando
bruciando soldi e quindi cosa fai Vai a
parlare dagli investitori quelli che ti
avevano messo i due milioni di euro i
più interessati in teoria non perdere
quei soldi vai dici caro investitore
vorrei che mi aiutassi e loro cominciano
a parlarti in una lingua strana
ti cominciano a dire Ma qual è la tua
vision e la tua Mission per i prossimi
cinque anni ma che sono Nostradamus cioè
che ne devo sapere tra cinque anni io
vorrei pagare gli stipendi Quale vuoi
fare un Bridge round o una convertible
note sarà una pratica sessuale Cioè ti
preoccupi e poi qual è il tuo answer
Advantage Insomma racconto spesso questo
aneddoto portai una mia amica Lucy che
oggi qui presente al questo magico mondo
degli eventi per start up presentò la
sua idea cioè un'azienda per il riciclo
è un certo punto dopo la presentazione
uno di questi investitori in giacca e
cravatta compito molto serio arrivò a
chiederle Ma qual è il tuo asset
principale
Lucy che era appunto una novellina
ingenuamente rispose
il mio asset il mio furgone Ford Transit
cioè il furgone col quale trasportava
questi oggetti riciclati Ecco la realtà
è che tra te la tua nano aziende tu
investitori si crea un mondo parallelo
tu cerchi di sopravvivere e loro giocano
un po' a fare i grandi Guru della
Silicon Valley offrendoti quattro spicci
per cambiare il mondo Ecco perché non
sempre avere degli investitori e la
scelta giusta per il tuo capitale
sociale
In realtà poi a noi andò bene nel senso
che scoprimmo quello che doveva essere
il nostro business Model come dicevo
prima come fare soldi con la spesa
online Bingo c'eravamo eravamo arrivati
al momento giusto al posto giusto una
grande catena del Nord aveva deciso di
lanciare in tutto il nord Italia Ecco
qui Questa è la campagna pubblicitaria
del 2015 tu vai alla beauty farm noi nel
frattempo ti prepariamo la spesa
Finalmente Era la strada che stavamo
cercando abbiamo aperto un bellissimo
ufficio in centro a Milano il fatturato
raddoppiava anno suo anno e avevamo ben
24 dipendenti ce l'abbiamo fatta
e invece no perché come dico sempre la
vita degli Imprenditori è un po' come le
montagne russe Up & Down Pensavamo di
essere usciti dalla Valle della Morte ma
non è così Perché Cosa è successo Beh un
paio di anni dopo la stessa società che
era il nostro principale ma anche unico
cliente decise di cambiare fornitore
legittimamente per cui noi ci ritrovammo
il primo gennaio del 2018 Dopo quattro
anni di splendore a dover ricominciare
da zero avevamo zero soldi in cassa ma
24 stipendi da pagare cosa fare
sicuramente stringere le chiappe
nel senso che è un momento triste perché
gli scienziati più di 10 persone alcuni
amici da una vita che non mi parlarono
più da quel momento
ricapitalizzare con i miei risparmi
l'azienda perché gli investitori non
volevano più mettere un euro Anzi
volevano liquidare
del nostro bellissimo loft in centro a
Milano fu chiuso e tornammo in quattro
in un coworking in stazione centrale a
Milano
Quindi direi che per noi era arrivato il
grande inverno
Forse nessuno lo sa ma ora lo sapranno
tutti per un anno e mezzo io rinunciai
al mio stipendio pur di pagare e aiutare
a pagare gli stipendi degli altri
qualcuno mi disse ma licenzia tutti e
aspetta tempi migliori io assolutamente
non volevo farlo anche un po' diciamo
incaponendomi sull'idea E allora cosa
abbiamo fatto ho incominciato a
incontrare tutti nuovi possibili
investitori
banche per un prestito che ovviamente
non mi diedero è possibile acquirenti
come anche acquirenti improbabili
incontrai amici di amici ma anche amici
di Nemici tutto per riuscire a
racimolare altri soldi e andare avanti
Eppure la verità è che noi in quel
momento non eravamo più sexy l'azienda
era sul mercato ormai da anni
l'ho speso online non è una tecnologia
che cambierà il mondo come
l'intelligenza artificiale
l'e-commerce non cresceva tanto come
mercato e io come imprenditrice In
realtà ero già vecchia Quindi nel mondo
delle startup dopo un paio di anni
eravamo vecchi
ci buttiamo Allora nella ruota del
criceto per forza dobbiamo riuscire auto
sostenerci cerchiamo più clienti
dovevamo acquisire più clienti possibili
stiracchiamo Un po' il tempo di
pagamento dei fornitori e nonostante
tutto Cercavo di dormire la notte però
in realtà non ci riuscivo
E durante uno di queste notti insonni a
un certo punto mi illumina d'immenso e
decisi mi dissi
svendiamo la concorrenza Barbara Basta
ok Non diventerai ricca questa volta e
parentesi non si fanno start up per
diventare ricchi Ok comunque non
diventerai ricchi questa volta ma almeno
hai fatto esperienza è un po' come
quando ti dicono Com'è il tuo nuovo
fidanzato ma è interessante un tipo no
cioè te la fai andare bene quindi
prepariamo il nostro contratto di
cessione siamo ormai Nel 2020 inizio del
2020 ragazzi 10 anni dopo
eravamo praticamente a Tara luce e vino
i miei dipendenti erano tutti salvi
sarebbero stati inglobati nella nuova
azienda e io anch'io diventavo una
dipendente come gli altri insomma tanto
rumore per nulla
Eppure come nelle migliori telenovelas
No il marito che è morto nella stagione
precedente si ripresenta alla cena di
Natale esattamente così ci fu il colpo
di scena attenzione alla data siamo
inizio del 2020 Cosa succede il covid
Inutile dirvi che in una notte si
decuplicarono le richieste di spesa
online sulle nostre piattaforme quello
che vedete qui è un grafico che vi
mostra l'andamento delle richieste della
spesa online rispetto a ogni dpcm del
presidente Conte Ok ogni dpcm c'era un
piccolo
noi cercavamo ovviamente di rispondere a
tutta questa risposta questa questa
domanda e abbiamo lavorato Credo dalle 5
del mattino fino alle 23:00 per più di
tre mesi Io ricordo che durante il
lockdown una mia vicina dalla casa di
fronte a un certo punto mi chiamò e mi
disse ma tu cosa fai di lavoro ho detto
Ma perché Che ti importa Ma no perché ti
vedo tutto il giorno urlare al telefono
perché cercavamo di gestire le consegne
a distanza
facevamo un servizio sociale per un
momento difficilissimo della nostra
Italia
Inutile dirvi che a questo punto del
contratto di cessione No forse abbiamo
deciso di fare un o la valvola spacca
ALL IN quindi non vendiamo più ci
concentriamo sul nostro business abbiamo
fatto una scommessa che comunque
l'e-commerce dal covidi in poi sarebbe
cominciato a crescere in modo rapido ma
costante e vi posso dire che ancora oggi
la scommessa È vinta perché comunque
cresce del 10% anno su anno ad Avercene
di business così ora vi chiedo Quanti di
voi hanno fatto fanno la spesa online a
Messina state la mano non ho detto chi
mangia la cioccolata prima di andare a
dormire alzate la mano Chi fa la spesa
bravi Ecco migliaia di persone ogni
giorno ci aprono la porta per ricevere
la loro spesa
sono famiglie numerose mamme con bambini
disabili sono persone anziane ma anche
semplicemente pigri molti pigri
ma anche semplicemente pigri quindi vi
lascio con tre insegnamenti tre cose che
ho imparato e anche con un
ringraziamento La prima è che se vuoi
fare start up devi fare dei sacrifici
per diverso tempo probabilmente dovrai
accantonare le tue passioni famiglia
amici tempo libero per raggiungere
quello che il tuo obiettivo cioè la
sostenibilità della tua azienda Quindi
se volete intraprendere questa avventura
Attenzione ci sono dei sacrifici da fare
secondo insegnamento le decisioni
qualsiasi decisione tu abbia preso in
realtà è quella giusta anche se poi si è
rivelata sbagliatissima perché perché in
quel momento storico con determinate
circostanze quello ed elementi Quella
era la decisione da prendere non esiste
un buon tempo un brutto tempo esiste una
buona decisione una brutta decisione si
decide con quello che ha in quel momento
quindi non rimborsi e non rimpianti
l'ultimo insegnamento che è anche un
ringraziamento e per dire che io ho
fatto tanti sacrifici e continua a farli
ho preso tanti rischi e continuo a
prenderli ma da sola non sarei potuta
resuscitare almeno tre volte Cioè in 10
minuti già sarei suscitata tre volte
nella storia No questo è possibile solo
grazie a un team quindi ringrazio Il mio
team e molti sono presenti anche oggi
perché senza un team che crede in te che
ti dà fiducia anche quando dici le cose
più strane ogni volta ogni singola volta
non sarebbe possibile riappiccicare i
cocci con loro Grazie
[Musica]